>>> 25 YEARS AGO,
STEVEN SPIELBERG OPENED THE
DOORS TO "JURASSIC PARK."
AND INSIDE THOSE DOORS --
SPOILER ALERT -- WERE DINOSUARS.
NOW, AS PART OF THE 25th
ANNIVERSARY RERELEASE, YOU CAN
WATCH THE 1992 SCREEN TESTS.
>> HUGH GRANT FOR
DR. ALLEN GRANT.
>> YES, UM, HATE TO BE A BOTHER,
BUT, UM --
IF YOU LOOK BEHIND YOU, THERE'S
A --
WELL, THERE'S A BOLT OF A T-REX.
AND I THOUGHT PERHAPS WE SHOULD
MOVE FASTER?
TO ESCAPE ITS -- RATHER LARGE
TEETH.
>> ALAN ALDA FOR MULDOON.
>> CLEVER GIRL.
WHEN THAT DINOSAUR COMES OUT AND
ATTACKS ME?
OH, YOU GUYS, THAT IS GREAT.
THAT IS JUST TERRIFIC.
AND HOW ARE YOU GOING TO SHOOT
THE DINOSAUR?
IS IT GONNA BE FORCED
PERSPECTIVE?
YOU KNOW, THAT'S HOW WE SHOT
JAMIE FARR ON "MASH."
YEAH, NO, HE'S ONLY ABOUT TWO
FEET TALL.
>> ELLEN DeGENERES FOR
DR. SATTLER.
>> ALL RIGHT, WOW!
THAT'S A GIGANTIC PILE OF DINO
POOP.
I'VE HAD STOOLS ON STAGE BEFORE,
BUT THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
I'M JUST KIDDING.
I'M '90s ELLEN.
>> SAY, I'M TELLIN' Y'ALL, TRUST
ME.
SPEND YOUR MONEY.
ALL RIGHT?
IRS CAN'T TAKE IT IF IT'S
ALREADY SPENT.
CAN'T TAKE SOMETHING ALREADY
GONE.
THAT'S A TAX LOOPHOLE FOR YOUR,
BROTHER.
>> WESLEY, COULD WE GET THE
LINE?
>> OH, YEAH.
BINGO, DINO DNA.
NOW IF YOU WANT MY ACCOUNT'S
NUMBER, I GOT YOU.
IT'S 1-900 --
>> ROSEANNE BARR FOR
JOHN HAMMOND.
>> WELCOME TO JURASSIC PARK.
DAN!
>> ADAM SANDLER FOR MULDOON.
[ MUMBLING ]
TURKEY-LURKEY DOO AND A
TURKEY-LURKEY DEE.
I LIKE THE T-REX, DOES T-REX
LIKE ME?
AH, SHUT UP!
>> WHOOPI GOLDBERG AS
DR. STATTLER.
>> WELL, LET'S TALK ABOUT IT.
'CAUSE THE LAST THING I NEED
RIGHT NOW IS DINOSAURS.
AND THEN I'LL GET THE DINOSAUR
LOOK LIKE --
>> PEE-WEE HERMAN --
>> AHH!
HA-HA.
AH-AH-AH, YOU DIDN'T SAY THE
MAGIC WORD!
HA!
HA-HA!
HE-HE.
ARG-ARG-ARG.
>> DREW BARRYMORE FOR
DR. STATTLER.
>> THERE ARE BRONTOSAURUSES AND
BRACHIOSAURSES AND
APATOSAURUSES.
BUT I HAVE TO WONDER, ARE WE
PLAYING GOD?
>> JOEY LAWRENCE FROM "BLOSSOM."
>> OKAY, REACT TO SEEING THE
DINOSAURS FOR THE FIRST TIME.
>> WHOA!
>> ALL RIGHT, WANT TO TRY
ANYTHING ELSE?
>> NO!
>> GWEN STEFANI AS THE TEENAGE
GIRL.
>> I'M JUST A GIRL.
DON'T EAT ME BIG DINOSAUR.
>> CAN WE GET A FRIGHTENED
SCREAM?
>> OHHH.
>> SINBAD.
>> NOW, Y'LL KNOW THAT MY WIFE
IS A TRICERATOPS, RIGHT?
YEAH.
I WAIT DOWNSTAIRS WHILE SHE
TRIES ON SEVERAL TOPS.
HOW Y'ALL DOING?
Y'ALL GOOD?
GOT YOUR LADY?
>> AL PACINO.
>> WELCOME TO JURASSIC PARK!
YOU DUMB [ BLEEP ]!
>> OKAY, MR. PACINO, THIS MOVIE
IS SUPPOSED TO BE PG.
>> PG?
THAT'S GONNA BE A [ BLEEP ]
NIGHTMARE FOR THIS GUY.
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
ALL RIGHT.
WHICH DINOSAUR DO I BUY THE
COCAINE FROM?
>> LISA KUDROW.
>> WELL, THERE'S THE T-REX.
AND MUST MOVE FASTER.
MUST MOVE FASTER!
OH, NO, OH, NO.
>> JALEEL WHITE.
>> OKAY, SO YOU JUST LET ALL THE
DINOSAURS LOOSE ON THE ISLAND.
>> DID I DO THAT?
I GOT BITCHES IN MY TRAILER,
DOG.
I GOTTA GO, MAN.
>> EDDIE VEDDER FOR THE
SOUNDTRACK.
♪ RAPTORS ARE OPENING
OPENING THE DOOR
DADDY -- ♪
>> JODIE FOSTER AS MR. DNA.
[ WHISPERING ]
SOMETIMES A MOSQUITO WOULD GET
CAUGHT IN THE SAP.
IT WAS SO STICKY.
SO STICKY.
>> COULD YOU TRY IT A LITTLE
HAPPIER?
>> THIS IS THE HAPPIEST I'VE
EVER BEEN.
TODAY IS MY BIRTHDAY.
>> O.J. SIMPSON.
>> OKAY.
SO, IF I DID LET THE DINOSAURS
OUT, LET ME TELL YOU HOW I WOULD
HAVE DONE IT.
HYPOTHETICALLY.
MAN, 1992!
IT IS GOOD TO BE O.J. RIGHT NOW.
AIN'T NOTHING GOING TO SLOW THIS
TRAIN DOWN.
GO O.J., GO.
>> CLINT EASTWOOD, TAKE ONE.
>> WELCOME TO JURASSIC PARK.